Is cleaning cathartic for you?
Like why?
Yes.
I like the notion that something is not right
and I have the power to make it right.
(laughter)
Do your sons, like what kind of stains do they create?
Generic, I mean honestly,
permanent marker is something that gets everywhere.
Usually it's my fault
but they participate sometimes as well.
Alright, so we have decided to take the hydrogen peroxide
route here at the show today.
Now here's the good news.
I have a fail safe, so I don't wanna bury the lead
and, and, and, and make this too comfortable for anyone.
Also, I'm loving this pouring situation.
My hydrogen peroxide has just the big opening.
This is like.
Yeah, this is fancy.
Do you know what I have that I'm really into,
a hydrogen peroxide that has a spray.
Okay, that's amazing.
This is what gets me hot.
That's amazing.
So we let the peroxide sit for a second.
There it is.
Hydrogen peroxide is a new tool.
I feel like I just made it worse.
I just made it worse.
(laughter)
Does it have to get worse before it gets better?
Is the fail safe throwing this out?
That might need, okay I'm gonna add more.
It's so funny, I approach stain remover very unlike
the rest of my life.
Is it not gonna come out
and you wanna make the neuroscientist look stupid?
Now I want you to, is there such a thing,
now I want you to take the baking soda.
Yes ma'am.
Put some on your toothbrush.
And then I just want you to sort of.
I'm gonna use this.
I'm liking all the dispensers here at the Drew Show.
I was gonna say, gently brush.
Are you implying that my vigorous brushing
is what made it worse?
Well.
It's kind of judge-y.
I'll tell you a little story about what happens
unfortunately when people vigorously brush
is that you are actually setting the stain into the fiber.
Why didn't you tell me that before?
I'm sorry.
I didn't know you were going in.
But, so what you wanna do is in stain removal,
you'd wanna do the opposite of what you think.
You lift, you lift.
And anytime you go in there like that
you are just setting it in there harder.
And so you wanna like, here feel this.
I don't wanna feel anything.
Feel this.
That's very soft.
Right?
Bunny paw, kitty.
What, okay.
Baby.
I need to know what the next phase is.
Okay, then we're gonna go back to the hydrogen peroxide
and do that.
See how it's changing color.
Okay now go back.
Now it looks like instead of just black Sharpie
it's red and blue.
(laughter)
And then you wanna get your toothbrush in there.
More, okay.
And then you wanna now try that gentle approach.
Make love to it, you know.
With my bunny paw of a toothbrush.
Make love to it with your bunny paw, exactly.
I lose.
Whatever game this was I just lost.
Well this isn't, this isn't perfect.
It's not easy.
You're, you're doing great.
And I, I.
You will pay for the therapy session I have about this.
I'm still dealing with a lot of red here.
We both are.
I've gotten down through the black.
You know if nothing else we've changed the color of it.
Absolutely.
Okay, so here.
You're getting a little vigorous.
I, yes, 'cause I'm feeling like I have nothing to lose.
Here's, here's what happens when you have nothing to lose.
Okay.
Bleach.
There's always an option.
True story.
Now I have buckets of water here
because what you wanna do is if you think,
you know you're having fiber problems
as you're rubbing that stain all over the place.
Let me pour you a shot.
Oops.
It's okay, it's white on, it's bleach on white.
Yep, exactly.
Okay so.
So this is where you go okay, forget it.
I'm not getting anywhere and you take your little toothbrush
Just a little bit.
And you just start going with the straight bleach.
And again, still try to.
It smells like the YMCA when I was a kid.
Ugh, I love that smell, the bleach and the pool.
Smells like learning to swim.
Okay do you see that?
It's like a magic eraser.
It's going away and then see that.
Oh, wow.
(applause)
Okay, so now.
You're good, not get it in the water.
Now get it in the water!
I'm not, I'm not there yet.
I'm not there yet.
I'm a little slower with my bleaching.
Oh, oh, it's working though.
I feel much better already.
Okay, so there we go.
And then I would.
Oh, wow.
I'll throw it straight in the wash.
Put it in the water now?
Do you see that?
(applause)
(laughter)
I did it?
It's gone.
The headline, we used bleach to remove a stain, we did it.
(applause)
I mean.
Hold your t-shirt up.
I mean, good as new.
We did it.
You did it.
(applause)
I'm proud of us.
You did it.
Now I wanna do it again.
And it's beautiful and you're perfect.
(upbeat music)